now onto news on the fight against covid
we may be getting closer to another
major decision on booster shots
yesterday a fda panel unanimously
supported modernist booster shot for
older americans and those at high risk
today a panel will consider if booster
shots are necessary for people who got
the johnson and johnson vaccine wii de
jang is at the white house where
president biden is also weighing in
ouija good morning good morning to you
nate and good morning to everybody
president biden says he expects a final
decision from the fda and the cdc on the
moderna and johnson and johnson booster
in the next couple weeks the decision he
says will be based on science as the
administration continues to battle
misinformation and tries to convince
vaccine holdouts to get their shots
we're headed in the right direction
president biden said his plan to get out
of the pandemic is working
but he called out the unvaccinated for
preventing more progress we're down to
66 million still unacceptably high
number of unvaccinated people from
almost 100 million
in july
many who got a modern vaccine could soon
have access to a booster
we do have a unanimous 19 out of 19 yes
vote
an fda advisory panel recommended a
third shot for seniors younger adults
with health problems and for anyone who
works or lives in a place that puts them
at a higher risk for contracting the
virus the dose will be half as much as
the first two shots the immune response
to the moderate vaccine seems a little
more robust and durable than the pfizer
biontech vaccine an authorization from
the fda could come in days then the cdc
would meet next week which would mean
the earliest that americans would be
able to get the moderna booster would
likely be next friday
the fda panel will also review a study
by the national institutes of health it
has not yet been peer reviewed but shows
that mixing and matching vaccines is
safe as a booster shot and then that
same group will decide later this month
whether to authorize the pfizer vaccine
for children between the ages of 5 and
11. tarika
luigi thank you